اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
الى العناوين
بعد تتقدم في بخمه وازيلين
لروسيا باستخدام الفوسفور الابيض
بريطانيا تحذر موسكو بعد تصادم طائره
مسيره امريكيه بمقاتله روسيه فوق البحر
الاسود
متظاهرون يحتشدون امام مطار بن غوريون
لمنع سفر نتنياهو الى برلين بسبب
التعديلات القضائيه
بحضور قادم فرنسي جلسه استجواب لحاكم مصر
في لبنان رياض سلامه في قضايا اختلاس
اموال عامه
دعا وزير الدفاع البريطاني بن واليس روسيا
الى احترام المجال الجوي الدولي وذلك
بعدما قالت الولايات المتحده ان روسيا
تسببت في تحطم احدى طائراتها المسيره في
البحر الاسود وشدد بنوالص على ضروره ان
يحترم جميع الاطراف المجال الجوي الدولي
لاسيما وان الامريكيين يعتقدون ان ما فعله
الروس لم يكن مهنيا من جانبه وصف زعيم
الاغلبيه الديمقراطيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكيه تشاك فومر قرارات الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين وجيشه بالاعمال الطائشه
محذرا بوتين من ان السلوك الروسي قد يؤدي
لتصعيد غير مقصود مع امريكا
عمل طائش اخر يقوم به الرئيس بوتين وجيشه
اود ان اقول للسيد بوتين اوقف هذا السلوك
قبل ان تكون سببا في تصعيد غير مقصود
شهدنا هذا السلوك الروسي من قبل ولا
يمنعنا من تنفيذ عمليات فوق البحر الاسود
هذه الاعمال العدوانيه من قبل الطائرات
الروسيه محفوفه بالمخاطر ويمكن ان تؤدي
مثل ما ذكرت الى تصعيد غير مقصود الطائرات
الامريكيه تحلق بشكل روتيني فوق البحر
الاسود قبل غزو بوتين المتهور لاوكرانيا
وانا واثق من ان جيشنا سيستمر في القيام
بذلك
قبل ذلك اكد المتحدث باسم البنتاجون انه
لن يفصح عن تفاصيل المعدات والمهمه التي
كانت تقوم بها المسيره الامريكيه في البحر
الاسود واوضح رايدر ان روسيا لم تعثر على
المسيره بعد سقوطها
لن اخوض في تفاصيل المعدات التي كانت على
متن الطائره المسيره كانت وحده مراقبه
وبسبب الضرر كنا في موقف دفعنا لتحطيمها
في البحر الاسود على حد علمي الروس لم
يستعيدوا هذه الطائره وعن جهود استعادتنا
لا توجد معلومات حتى الان ونقيم الموارد
التي لدينا في هذه المنطقه
اما وزاره الدفاع الروسيه فنفت روايه
البنتاغون بشان حادث اسقاط طائره مسيره
امريكيه فوق البحر الاسود وقالت الدفاع
الروسيه ان المسيره الامريكيه اقتربت من
المجال الجوي الروسي فوق شبه جزيره القرم
حسب بيانها واضافت الوزاره ان المسيره
الامريكيه اغلقت اجهزه تعريفها فانطلقت
مقاتلات روسيه كانت في مهمه في المنطقه
الى موقع المسيره ونفت الدفاع الروسيه ان
تكون مقاتلاتها استخدمت الذخيره ضد
المسيره الامريكيه او قامت حتى بالاقتراب
بشكل خطير منها مشيره الى ان المسيره قامت
بمناوره حاده تسببت فيه خسارتها لارتفاعها
وفقدانها السيطره لينتهاء لينتهي بها
الامر بالارتطام بسطح البحر فيما جدد
السفير الروسي في واشنطن اناتولي انتونوف
تاكيده بان المسيره الامريكيه التي سقطت
فوق البحر الاسود اتجهت بثبات وبشكل
استفزازي باتجاه الاراضي الروسيه وقال في
بيان نشرات والسفاره ان المسيره الامريكي
او تلك المسيرات تجمع معلومات استخباراتيه
تستخدمها بعد ذلك لضرب روسيا وضع واشنطن
الى وقف عمليات التحليق العدائيه او ارسال
اي مقاتلات او مسيرات جويه بالقرب من
الحدود الروسيه واشار الى ان انشطه الجيش
الامريكي على مقربه شديده من حدود روسيا
هي غير مقبوله وتثير القلق
ننطلق الان
لننتقل الى كلمه رئيس الوزراء العراقي
خلال منتدى السليمانيه السابع ويركز خلاله
على حرب العراق بعد مرور 20 عاما جات
المياه الثقيله ووقعنا مؤخرا عقود جوله
التراخيص الخامسه للاستثمار الغاز المصاحب
ووقف في حرقه لخفض الانبعاثات الكربونيه
بنسب كبيره وسنمضي في تطوير المشاريع التي
تحول الغاز المصاحب الى مصدر مهم للطاقه
الكهربائيه
ولم نتوقف عند حصر المشكله وتحديدها بل
اطلقنا مبادره كبرى للتسجير تشمل زراعه
خمسه ملايين شجره ونخله في عموم محافظات
العراق يرافقها اطلاق دليل وطني للتشجير
الحضري ولاول مره في العراق واخيرا
يجب ان لا ننسى ان العراق قد حارب نيابه
عن العالم اجمع الجماعات التكفيريه الاكثر
شراسه في التاريخ ولولا هذا البلد العظيم
والغني باهله وصلابته واصراره على محاربه
جماعات الارهاب لعاثت في الارض شرا وفسادا
استمرت باعمالها ومخططاتها الاجراميه في
باقي بقاع المعموره من اقصى الشرق الى
اقصى الغرب عراقنا يرى ان العالم يمكنه ان
يتعلم الدروس الكثيره والغزيره من معركه
الشعب العراقي بمختلف اعراقه واديانه في
حربه ضد الارهاب وان يتعلم الدرس الازمه
المتمثل بالوحده والتعاون والجديه
والاصرار وانها ستكون المصد الاقوى في وجه
الارهاب
سيبقى العراق قويا بتماسك كل مكوناته
وشعبه فالعراق هو بلد المكونات والتعدديات
والثقافات والديانات المختلفه تجتمع تحت
ظل بيتنا الكبير العراق الذي ليس لنا غيره
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
قال للنقل ابدا بان تكون ارضنا منطلقا
لهجمات ضد الدول الجوار وانه يجب مغادره
المشاكل العالقه مع اقليم كردستان الى
مشروعات مستدامه
وايضا شدد على انه الحكومه مصممه على ضبط
الحدود ومنع عمليات التسلل والتهريب
ونعود الى موضوع حادثه التصادم بين
المسيره الامريكيه والمقاتله الروسيه
وينضم الينا عبر سكايب من موسكو رائد جبر
مدير مكتب جريده الشرق الاوسط في موسكو
اهلا بك سيد رائد يعني هل برايك هو فعلا
حادث تصادم عادي يحصل بين طائره ومسيره ام
انه هو فعل متعمد لانه حسب التوصيف ياتي
رد الفعل كما تعلم
نعم تحيه طيبه يعني بصرف النظر عن تباين
المعطيات التي قدمتها موسكو واشنطن حول
الحادث وانه لم يكن الحادث تصادم كما قالت
موسكو ولكن هذا الحدث اظهر درجه خطوره
انقطاع الاتصالات قنوات الاتصال والتنسيق
العسكريه بين الطرفين بشكل نهائي يعني على
مدار سنوات كان هناك قنوات الاتصال منعت
مثلا وقوع صدامات مماثله في الاجواء
السوريه الان هذه الاتصالات مقطوعه
وبالتالي هذا الحادث يؤشر الى مدى خطوره
يعني ان تتواصل هذه الصدمات من هذا النوع
ان تحدث اكثر من مره وربما تتحول الى
مواجهه غير مقصوده النقطه الثانيه المهمه
هنا انه هذه الطائره المسيره الامريكيه
دخلت الى منطقه اعلنت موستوس في فتره
سابقه انها منطقه حظر يعني طيران لكن
المجتمع الدولي لا يعترف بهذه المنطقه
الروسيه بالتالي روسيا لديها روايتها بان
هذه اجواء روسيه بعد ضم القرن بينما الغرب
لا يعترف بهذه المساله هذه النقطه ايضا ت
ؤثر في الفتره المقبله ايضا الاستخبارات
يعني الحديث حول انه المسيرات الامريكيه
تجمع معلومات استخباراتيه لصالح اوكرانيا
هذا امر يعني جديد واليوم ليس جديدا عفوا
وانما يتكرر كثيرا على السنه المسؤولين
الروس وحديث السفير الروسي لدلالات
المتحده ان تعرف في هذا الشان مؤشر ايضا
ربما تكون هذه رساله من جانب موسكو الى
الاستخبارات الغربيه الى الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا وغيرها من البلدان الغربيه بانه
موسكو لن تقف مكتوفه الايدي طويلا امام
يعني حركه طائرات الاستطلاع والمسيرات
التي تجمع المعلومات وتقدمها الى الجيش
الاوكراني لضرب منشات في جزيره القرم او
ربما في مناطق اخرى داخل العمق الروسي سيد
رائد قبل ان انتقل الى الجزء الميداني اود
ان اسالك باختصار لو سمحت عن تداعيات هذا
الحادث هل سيبقى باطار العتاب الدبلوماسي
بين واشنطن وموسكو او يمكن ان يتطور لانه
حسب ما نرى بالمعلومات المتوفره لا يوجد
هناك توصيف لما حدث ماذا حدث بالتحديد
ماذا عن الطيار هل هنالك من صاروخ استخدم
بفقدان او بتدمير المسيره الامريكيه لا
معلومات
صحيح تماما وهنا تكبر خطوره هذا الحادث
لانه بالفعل يمكن ان يتكرر يعني الولايات
المتحده لن توقف طلعاتها كما بات واضحه
لن توقف طلعت الاستطلاعيه في هذه المنطقه
موسكو تصر على انه هذه المنطقه تقع في
اجوائها وبالتالي تصر على حمايتها لذلك
هذا الحدث يمكن ان يتكرر ربما تكون هذه
اشاره كما قلت الى خطوره انقطاع الاتصالات
ولكن هذا يعني انه الحادث قد يتكرر اكثر
من مره يعني لديها يمكن ان نتخيل مثلا
ماذا لو كانت هذه طائره عسكريه امريكيه
وسقطتلى في هذا الحادث كيف سيكون رد فعل
لذلك نحن امام تطور خطر ويمكن ان يؤدي الى
انزلاق نحو مواجهه غير مباشره وغير مقصوده
بين الطرفين في بشكل او باخر ويبدو انه
هناك حرص من الطرفين على عدم كما
ذكر توضيح كل البيانات المتعلقه بهذا
الحادث بالتالي هناك اصرار لدى كل طرف على
مواقفه السابقه ما يؤسس يعني الحاله خطره
في
المستقيم د
ائم بوقوع مواجهه غير مقصوده بين الاط
راف بين جانب اخر ابقى معي سيد رائد جبر
وساذهب
لعده اخبار ميدانيه حيث اعلنت مجموعه
فاغنر الروسيه تحقيق قواتها تقدما جديدا
في المنطقه الصناعيه بباخ التي تشهد قتالا
عنيفا مع تحسن القوات الاوكرانيه داخلها
وذكرت فاجنر في بيان لها ان قوتها خاضت
قتالا ليليا عنيفا وصعبا ضد القوات
الاوكرانيه باتجاه وسط وتمكنت من السيطره
على مصانع للمعادن واقتربت من السيطره على
اربعه مواقع جديده داخل مخ اكد الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي بعد اجتماعه
بالقاده العسكريين اكد التاييد بالاجماع
لمواصله الدفاع عن باخمت في دونيسك
تلقيته تقاريرا من القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه تفيد بان محور الاهتمام الرئيسي
في باخموت وزابالوجيا ولدينا موقف واضح
التعزيز العسكري في هذا القطاع وتدمر
المحتلين الى اقصى حد كما تلقينا معلومات
حول
بالاضافه الى المناطق الجنوبيه والشماليه
نحن نزود هذه المناطق بالضخيره والاسلحه
الروتينيه
حدث وكاله بان القوات الروسيه اطلقت ذخيره
تحتوي على ماده الفوسفور الابيض على منطقه
غير ماهوله في مدينه تشاسيفيار قرب مدينه
التي تشهد اعنف المعارك بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيا وبحسب الوكاله تسببت
كرات الفوسفور بحرائق في المساحات
المزروعه على جانبي الطريق الجنوبيه
تحديدا في الضواحي الجنوبيه لمدينه
تشاسيفيار ولم يتسنى الفرانس براس التاكد
مما اذا كان الموقع المستهدف هو مركز
للقوات الاوكرانيه وتتهم كياف موسكو بانها
استخدمت هذا النوع من الاسلحه مرارا منذ
بدء الحرب بما في ذلك ضد مدنيين وهو ما
ينفيه الجيش الروسي بشده
ما هو الفوسفور الابيض الفوسفور الابيض
ماده شفافه شبيهه بالشمع يشتعل بسهوله في
الهواء عند حوالي 30 درجه مئويه
يصنف كاسلحه حارقه ويستخدم بشكل اساسي
لصنع سواتر من الدخان
النوع المستعمل في الاغراض العسكريه يتميز
بشده نشاطه كيماويا يتسبب الفسفور الابيض
لحروق كيماويه مؤلمه لا يعتبر الفسفور
الابيض سلاحا كيماويا بموجب المعاهدات
الدوليه
اذا الشرطه الباكستانيه تنسحب الان من
محيط منزل عمران خان بعد اشتباكات عنيفه
مع انصار نتابع ذكرت صحيفه البريطانيه ان
روسيا ترسل النساء المدنات بتهم في السجون
الروسيه الى ساحات القتال في شرق اوكرانيا
واوضحت الصحيفه ان هذا الادعاء جاء من قبل
الجيش الاوكراني وايده رئيس جماعه روسيا
لحقوق الانسان واكدت هيئه الاركان العامه
الاوكرانيه انهم شاهدوا قطارا يقلوا نزلات
روسيات بالسجون في الاسبوع الماضي متجها
الى منطقه دنيا
وانضم الينا من جديد من موسكو رائد جابر
مدير مكتب جريده الشرق الاوسط في موسكو
سيد رائد اهلا بك من جديد يعني هذه ليست
المره الاولى الذي التي تتهم فيها موسكو
باستخدام
مواد ممنوعه دوليا مثل الفوسفور الان في
بخموت وهو الامر الذي تنفيه بشده
تماما موسكو
في صحه هذه المعطيات بشده
المعطيات الغربيه تحدثت اكثر من مره في
السابق عن هذا الامر يبدو انه معركه فخمه
بالفعل هي يعني نقطه مفصليه
واللافت الموضوع انه تزامن الاعلان الغربي
عن كشف يعني مؤسس باغنار
عن انه ارسل التعزيزات اضافيه الى باخ اذا
هناك اصرار من جانب كورينا على مواصله
يعني الدفاع عن هذه المدينه وتعزيز يعني
خطوط الدفاعيه تحصينها بالتالي قد يمكن
تفسير يعني استخدام اسلحه خارقه من هذا
النوع بانه محاوله لكسر معنويات الجيش
الاوكراني محاوله لتحقيق اختراق سريع او
على الاقل وقف محاولات تعزيز يعني
التحصينات بالقرب وحول هذه المدينه اذا
نحن امام مشهد متطور كما تعلمين تشهد
منذ شهور حتى الان لا يتمكن اي طرف من حسب
المعركه لصالحه يعني كل الحسابات يمكن ان
تدخل باتجاه انه الروسي يريدون تسريع
وتيره السيطره انجاز
انت تتحدث حضرتك وتنقل عن الاتحاد
الاوروبي بانه سيخسس مليار يورو لشراء
ذخيره لصالح اوكرانيا يعني تسليح الغرب
لاكياف لا يزال مستمر والتصعيد ايضا من
قبل الجانب الروسي ايضا
صحيح تماما انه هذه هي المشكله الرئيسيه
لا افاق للحل السياسي بينما الاصرار على
الحل العسكري من الجانبين بات هو المسيطر
بالامس استمعنا للتصريحات الكرمله نحاول
انه لا حل الا الحل العسكري في في
اوكرانيا بالمقابل امدادات العسكريه
والتسليحيه الغربيه لكيف تدل على انه هذا
الخيار ايضا هو المطروح امام
حتى الان لا يوجد اي افق سياسي بالتالي
هذا الاصرار من جانب الطرفين على هذا
السيناريو يدفع الى استخدام كل الطاقات
الممكنه بما في ذلك ربما اسلحه محرمه
بالمناسبه موسكو ايضا كانت اتهمت كيا في
اوقات سابقه بانها استخدمت بعض الالغام
والاسلحه التي محرمه القوانين الدوليه
بالتالي هذه اتهامات متبادله بجزء كبير
منها ربما يدخل في الحرب الاعلاميه بين
الطرفين لكن ايضا على ارض الواقع تم تسجيل
بالفعل حدوث يعني وقوع حوادث من هذا النوع
وتاكيدا على كلامك سيد رائد يعني العديد
من المراسلينا خلال تغطياتهم بدنيات يعني
كانوا يقولون كنا من خلال الصوت نعرف ما
الاسلحه المستخدمه الان لا نعرف ما هي من
كثر تنوعها وقوتها
صحيح صحيح تماما
يبدو انه خلال الاسابيع الاخيره في محاوله
من جانب موسكو لحسم هذه المعركه انتقلت
الى استخدام اسلحه اكثر يعني قوه اكثر
يعني قدره تدميريه هذا ظهر من خلال طبيعه
الصواريخ التي ضربت بعض المدن الاوكرانيه
في الفتره الاخيره ليست مماثله للضربات
المسيرات والصواريخ التي كانت تستخدمها في
اوقات سابقه وظهر ايضا ميدانيه بشكل مباشر
على خطوط التماس كلها من خلال القدرات
التفجيريه والتدميريه لبعض انواع الاسلحه
المستخدمه شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من موسكو عبر
سكايبرا الجابر مدير مكتب جريده الشرق
الاوسط في موسكو
شكرا افاده النائب الاول لرئيس لجنه مجلس
الدوما قسطنطين زاتولين بوجود تعديلات على
قانون الجنسيات الروسي التعديل يتضمن
الحرمان من الجنسيه الروسيه المكتسبه في
حاله الخيانه وتشويه سمعه العمليه
العسكريه الجاريه باوكرانيا بحسب المسؤول
الروسيه لوكاله سبوتنك ونص المشروع مشروع
القانون كذلك على الحرمان من الجنسيه بسبب
جرائم خطيره ضد الدوله وجرائم متعلقه
بالاتجار بالمخدرات وتزوير الوثائق نشرتنا
مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
الشرطه الباكستانيه تنسحب من محيط منزل
عمران خان بعد اشتباكات عنيفه مع انصاره
ووزير داخليه يتعهد باعتقاله ويقول انه
يختبئ كالفار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد انسحبت الشرطه
الباكستانيه من محيط منزل عمران خان رئيس
الوزراء السابق بعد اشتباكات عنيفه مع
انصاره وتحاول القوات من الشرطه كانت
التقدم نحو مقر اقامه عمران خان الاعتقاله
بامر قضائي لكن من دون جدوى بسبب الطوق
الذي يفرضه انصاره حول مسكنه واوضح رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمرا خان بانه
تعهد ضمنيا بانه سيمثل امام المحكمه في
الثامن عشر من مارس مؤكدا انه هو بحسب
الماده السادسه والسبعين من قانون
الاجراءات الجنائيه لا يحق لهم القبض عليه
اليوم قدمت تعهدا من خلال اشتياق خان رئيس
محكمه اللاهور العليا حاول تسليمه الى
نائب المفتش العامل الشرطه الذي كان قادما
لاعتقالي كما ادلى بتصريح علني مفرده ان
نائب المفتش لم يقابله عمدا وفقا للماده
السادسه 76 من قانون الاجراءات الجنائيه
اذا كان قد تم تسليم هذه الكفاله فلا يمكن
القبض علي بعدها
وقال وزير الداخليه الباكستانيه رانا ثناء
الله ان الرئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
المختبئ في منزله كالفار على حد وصفه
سيعتقل ويعرض على المحكمه
اليوم يختبئ في منزله مثل الفار لكننا
سنخرجه اليوم
سنعتقله اليوم ونعرضه على المحكمه
يعقد مجلس الامن الدولي اليوم اجتماعا
لمناقشه مستجدات الازمه اليمنيه والجهود
الراميه الى ارساء وقف رسمي لاطلاق النار
تمهيدا لبدء عمليه سياسيه شامله تقود الى
التسويه مستدامه للصراع تحت اشراف الامم
المتحده وساعقد المجلس جلسه احاطت لها
مشاورات مغلقه تتناول التحديثات الاخيره
بشان جهود السلام والاوضاع العسكريه
والانسانيه في اليمن ياتي ذلك بعد انطلاق
جوله جديده من مفاوضات تبادل الاسرى بين
الحكومه اليمنيه
وميليشيا الحوثي في جوناف
اطلقت المعارضه الاسرائيليه دعوات
لمظاهرات كبيره رافضه لسياسات واجراءات
الحكومه الحاليه ووفق الدعوات يعتزم
الاسرائيليون التظاهر قرب مطار بن غوريون
بالمركبات لعرقله سفر رئيس الحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو وزوجته سار الى برلين حيث
من المقرر ان يلتقي برئيس المانيا وافادت
المصادر بان نحو الف اكاديمي طالبوا سفراء
المانيا وبريطانيا من اجل العمل على الغاء
زياره نتنياهو لبلديهما
وتنضم الينا من مطار تل ابيب مراسله
العربيه اهلا بك لانا يعني باي ساعه ستبدا
هذه المظاهره التي دعي اليها من قبل منظمي
المظاهرات الاخيره والتي ينمون من خلالها
عرقله سفر نتنياهو
صحيح يعني منذ صباح اليوم بدات مظاهرات
حتى في القدس من امام مقر رئيس الوزراء في
القدس ويعني سوف تبدا ايضا مظاهرات هنا في
مطار بن غريون لانه من المقرر ان يسافر
فعليا بنيامين نتنياهو من هذا المطار الى
العاصمه الالمانيه بالريم هناك خطه فعليا
وضعها المتظاهرين وهي محاوله بالسير
بمركباتهم بطريقه بطيئه فعليا في شوارع
المطار وبالرغم من وجود الحواجز تمكنوا في
المره الماضيه ايضا من الدخول في المطار
نعم لانا كان هناك خبر بانه الكنيست وافق
على قانون يمنع السجن او عزل نتنياهو ماذا
في تفاصيل هذا الخبر
صحيح يعني وجاءت ايضا هذه المظاهرات من
اجل مصادقه الكنيست بالقراءه الاولى على
قانون ايضا التغلب وهو تغلب فعليا الكنيست
على المحكمه العليا بطبيعه الحال المحكمه
العليا هي كانت الاعلى في الهيئه القضائيه
الاعلى ايضا في اسرائيل وهي تستطيع ايضا
ان تلغي قوانين يعني تم الموافقه عليها من
قبل الكنيست وما تحاول هاي او ما يحاول
فعليا لنتنياهو وحكومته ان يقوم بتغلب على
المحكمه العليا ويحاول ان يعني يضع
الكنيست كانه هيئه اعلى من المحكمه وهذا
ما يعارضه
المتظاهرين يعني وراينا للاسبوع العاشر
على التوالي هناك مظاهرات يخرج مئات
الالاف من الاسرائيليين للتظاهر ضد هذه
التعديلات القضائيه وبالرغم من هذه
المظاهرات
الحاشده والمظاه اللي ايدها ايضا جنود من
الاحتياط وهذا امر خطير نحن نرى الجنود او
الجيش حاليا يضع في الوسط وهذا امر غير
مسبوق في اسرائيل وهو امر خطير وبالرغم من
هذه الاجراءات نتنياهو مازال مستمر في
التعديلات القضائيه وما زالت المظاهرات
سوف نشهد اليوم ايضا مظاهره كبرى سوف تقوم
بتعطيل حركه السير في مطار بن غريون
الدولي هنا في هذا المطار نحن نتواجد فيه
ويعني راينا ايضا حاله تاهب هناك في في
صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي هناك اعداد كبيره
من الشرطه الاسرائيليه تتواجد على المداخل
وايضا تقوم يعني تفتيش او تعمل لفات فعليا
في المطار للتاكد من ان المظاهرات لم تبدا
حتى الان ولكن في سماء في تمام الساعه 12
ظهرا سوف يخرج اعداد كبيره من المتظاهرين
لمنع حركه السير هنا في مطار بن غريون
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من مطار تل ابيب مراسله
العربيه لان اكل غازي
في شمال الاهواز يستمر اضراب العمال
الموسميين في شركه صناعات قصب السكر
ويطالب العمال الموسميون بتحويل عقودهم
الى دائمه
واظهرت مقاطع فيديو اضرابا لسائق الشاحنات
في مدينه شيراز الايرانيه احتجاجا على
زياده الرسوم على مخازن الفواكه والخطر
[موسيقى]
بدون كهرباء
هذه سنه حزينه للغايه كنت احب الاحتفال
بنوروز لكنني غير سعيده لم اشتري طعام
نروز التقليدي كالاسماك الذهبيه والاعشاب
وهو ما كنت افعله دائما في الماضي حزينه
لاننا فقدنا العديد من شبابنا والوضع
الاقتصادي مترددا اتعاطف مع الامهات
اللائي فقدنا احبائهن اشعر بالحزن ولو
واصلته بحديث ربما سابكي
اذا لم يكن لديك ما يكفي من المال للبقاء
على قيد الحياه والاطعام اسرتك بالطبع
فناس يكونون غير سعداء انا متاكد من ان
نظام الايراني يعرف المشكله ويعلم انه
يتعين عليه القيام بشيء ما سياسيا وهذا
مهم جدا وما يحدث سيء جدا لايران
لا استطيع ان افعل شيئا السلع باهظه الثمن
في الاسواق ناتي لنسال فقط عن الاسعار
ولكننا في الواقع غير قادرين على شراء اي
شيء على النظام ان يفهم ان الاسعار باهظه
حقا
وبعد سته اشهر لا تزال الاحتجاجات التي
عمت الشوارع الايرانيه منذ مقتل الشابه
الكرديه ماسه امينه
شعله لم تنطفئ في ايران بعد سته اشهر على
مقتلها اتهمت بانها ترتدي لباسا غير لائق
ثم اقتيدت الى مركز الشرطه ثم قتلت
لتسبب وفاتها موجه احتجاجات لا تزال
مستمره حتى اليوم
فالاصوات التي ملات شوارع المدن الايرانيه
لا مطلب لها سوى العداله والحريه
والمساواه
الغضب الذي اشعلته وفاه مهسا ترافق مع
سلسله مشاكل خصوصا الازمه الاقتصاديه
وسلوك شرطه الاخلاق
احتجاجات اعتقل فيها الالاف واعدم العشرات
في خطوه قالت المعارضه انها لترهيب
المحتجين
افادت مصادر وقضائيه في لبنان بانطلاقه
جلسات الاستماع الى حاكم مصرف لبنان
المركزيه سلامه تنفيذا للاستنابات
القضائيه الاوروبيه واستكمالا للتحقيق
الذي بداته دول اوروبيه قبل سنتين وركزت
تحقيق على التحويلات الماليه من حسابات
حاكم المركزي وشقيقه رجع الى مصارف
اوروبيه وتحديد مصدر هذه الاموال على ان
يدير هذه الجلسات التي ستستغرق ثلاثه ايام
قاده تحقيق الاول في بيروت شربل ابو سمره
بحضور الوفود الاوروبيه التي وصلت الى
لبنان لهذه المهمه
[موسيقى]
وتنضم الينا حول هذا الموضوع من بيروت
مراسله العربيه رينادويه اهلا بك رينا
يعني انطلقت جلسات الاستماع الى رياض
سلامه حيث تتواجدين انت يبدو من امام
المحكمه فعليا او العدليه فعليا هل سيشارك
الفريق فريق التحقيق الاوروبي
بسؤال رياض سلامه ام سيكتفون بالاستماع
لما يحدث
نعم صباح الخير انها الساعه العاشره ونصف
تماما بتوقيت بيروت هذا هو الموعد الرسمي
لانطلاق جلسه استجواب رياض سلامه نحن خارج
قصر العدل بمطلق الاحوال هذه البوابه
الرئيسيه خلفيه شهيد الدخول الوفد القضائي
الاوروبي لكننا لا نعلم اذا كان رياض
سلامه اصبح في الداخل ام لا لانه بمطلق
الاحوال قد يسلك مدخلا اخر الوفد الاوروبي
اذا وصل قبل حوالي ربع ساعه من موعد
انطلاق المحاكمه هي المره الاولى التي
سيمثل بها سلام امام القضاء الاوروبي اذا
هو مطلوب بموجب استنابه قضائيه اوروبيه
وليس بموجب الدعاوي التي مرفوعه عليه من
قبل القضاء اللبناني الوفد الاوروبي يراسه
يعني تتواجد فيه قاضيه فرنسيه تمثل فرنسا
والاكسونبورج وممثل قنصل المانيا وهم
سيشاركون في هذه الجلسه دون القدره على
طرح اسئله مباشره الى الى سليمه بما يتعلق
بالسياده القانون واستقلاليته لذلك من
يدير هذه الجلسه هو القاضي شربيل ابو سمره
وكان الوافد قد التقي القاضي ابو سم
هل من مؤشرات على ذلك بالاجواء اللبنانيه
لانه عاده التصريحات يعني التصريحات عاده
سيتم التمديد له او لا
اعتقد انه ولايه تنتهي في نهايه
مايو ولكن يعني قد لا تنتهي قبلها هذه
التحقيقات بمطلق الاحوال الرياض سلامه
يشغل منصبه كما قلت من اكثر من 30 عاما
وبذلك يكون يمكن اطول حاكم في حكام في
تاريخ حكام المراكز المصرفيه هو رغم كل
الدعوه التي بحقه ومنع السفر الذي سطرته
القضيه غدا الا انه لا يزال على منصبه حتى
يومنا هذا اذا كان سيحضر او لا يحضر هذا
هو السؤال البديهي الذي يمكن ان يطرح الان
كوننا لا نعرف اذا كان داخل اروقات العدل
ولكن المعلومات كلها تقاطعت عند حضوره هذه
الجلسه شخصيا لاسباب تتعلق بعدم يعني ليس
في وارد ان يتخلف عن الاجراءات الاوروبيه
من جهه ومن جهه اخرى كون وكلائه
القانونيين لم يقدموا اي دفوعا شكليه
بالنيابه عنه لعدم الحضور فنحن ايضا نترقب
مشاركه رياض سلامه في جلسه اليوم سيكون له
محاميان واحد فرنسي واخر لبناني وستكون
ستشهد
جلسه الاستجواب وجود مترجمين اثنين
سيعملان على نقل الاسئله من القاضي ابو
سمره الى
الى رياض سلامه نعم شكرا جزيلا لك
رينادويه من امام قصر العدل في بيروت حيث
جلسه الاستماع الى رياض سلامه بحضور وفد
اوروبي بتهمه اختلاس اموال
الشعب اللبناني
في ظل حربها المستمره على المراه اغلقت
حركه طالبان المكتبه النسائيه الوحيده في
العاصمه كابول بعد سته اشهر فقط على
افتتاحها
حطوا المكتبه هنا في كابول لم تسلم طالما
ارتبط اسمها بالنساء فحرب طالبان على
المراه لم تتوقف بعد وتطالب كل ما يتعلق
بها
في احدث فصول هذه الحرب اقدمت حركه طالبان
على اغلاق المكتبه النسائيه الوحيده في
العاصمه الافغانيه بعد سته اشهر فقط من
افتتاحها مسؤول المكتبه قالوا انهم
اغلقوها لاسباب امنيه وفرض قيود على
النساء من قبل حركه طالبان الى جانب تعرض
المكتبه للهجوم مرتين من قبل طالبان
لتنتهي القصه باغلاقها نهائيه
اغلاق المكتبه التي شكلت الملجا الوحيد
للفتيات في كابو يقابله اصرار من النساء
على افتتاح مكتبات سريه ردا على اقصاء
طالبان الممنهج له مع التوجه الحاد للحركه
في القضاء على حقوق المراه تتضاءل الامال
في تاثير التحركات الدوليه للضغط على
السلطه حرمت النساء ليس من العمل والتعليم
فقط بل وحتى ارتياد المرافق العامه
والترفيهيه
في اخر تحرك دولي تجاه ما تمارسه الحركه
فرض الاتحاد الاوروبي في الثامن من الشهر
الجاري عقوبات عن وزير التعليم العالي في
طالبان لدى محمد نديم بسبب مسؤوليته عن
الانتهاك الواسع لحق المراه في التعليم
وزير اعلن علنا انه يريد قتل كل ما يخالفه
اطلق وزير الداخليه السوداني المكلف
الفريق عناننا عمر مبادره للتظاهر السلمي
وفق القانون اثناء كلمه القاها امام قوات
الشرطه في الخرطوم واكد الفريق عنان ان اي
اعتداء على مراكز الشرطه سيتم التعامل معه
بحسم وفقا للقانون
اوصل رساله للناس المشاركين في الحراك نحن
عندنا ما عندنا قضيه باي تجمعات في
الميادين ما عندنا القضيه بيتجمعات في
الاحياء نحن قضيتنا ما في زول يجينا في
المواقع الحاكمه للمواقع الاستراتيجيه نحن
اي زول موقع اي زول موقع سلام
لجنه الترتيبات الامنيه يورينا ناس وملوك
وشغالين شنو ويحفظ معاه الامر لكنها ما
ممكن نخلي جهه تدعي انها هي موقعه او هي
ما معروف كل المشاكل والجرائم يعني
بالنسبه لنا نضبطها
نلقاها وما نعرف الجهه المسؤوله منها
موقعه تتعاهم على الولايه مع شرطه الولايه
مع ريال المحليات لكن ما بنعترف به وما
بنسمح علينا في اقسامنا نوجه الناس لتنوي
القانون التزموا بالقانون ما عندنا حاجه
غير القانون ما عندنا حاجه ناخذها
تتقدم في باخ متوازيلينس كي يتعهدوا
بمواصله القتال واتهامات لروسيا باستخدام
الفوسفور الابيض
بريطانيا تحذروا موسكو بعد تصادم طائره
مسيره امريكيه بمقاتله روسيه فوق البحر
الاسود
متظاهرون يحتشدون امام مطار بن غوريون
لمنع سفر نتنياهو الى برلين بسبب
التعديلات القضائيه
بحضور قادم فرنسي جلسه استجواب لحاكم مصرف
لبنان رياض سلامه في قضايا اختلاس اموال
عامه
اهلا بكم من جديد تشهد فرنسا اليوم الموجه
الثامنه من التحرك الاحتجاجي ضد خطه
الحكومه رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما سيكون
يوما للاضراب والتظاهر حيث يشمل الاضراب
عددا واسعا من القطاعات اهمها الطاقه
والمواصلات الداخليه والنقل هيئه الطيران
المدني اعلنت انها طلبت الغاء 20% من
الرحلات الجويه من مطار اورلي بما يخص
التظاهرات الموكب الفارسي سيتحرك بعد ظهر
اليوم وسيتزامن مع دراسه لجنتين من مجلس
النواب والشيوخ لمشروع قانون اصلاح نظام
التقاعد من اجل التوصل الى نص متوافق عليه
من الطرفين اذ صوت مجلس الشيوخ السبت
الماضي لصالح المشروع بينما لا يزال الامر
عالقا في مجلس النواب الذي لم يتمكن من
التصويت عليه بعد
وتفقد مدينه النور بريقها بعد تراكم
القمامه على ارصفه باريس بسبب استمرار
اضراب عمال الصرف الصحي وجامعي القمامه
وينضم الينا من باريس مراسل العربيه فادي
الدهوك اهلا بك معنا فادي يعني اضراب عمال
النظافه يتواصل وكذلك الاحتجاجات ماذا في
تفاصيل
حل وسط
للقديتين والاحتجاجين
صباح الخير راويه نحن الان في الايام
الاخيره من اجل اقرار او رفض مشروع رفع سن
التقاعد الى 64 عاما قبل نصف ساعه من الان
بدا اجتماع لجنتين من
مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي وايضا مجلس النواب
لجنه مشتركه ستناقش نصا مشتركا بين
المجلسين لرفعه لاحقا الى التصويت لمجلس
الشيوخ يوم غد ومن ثم الى مجلس النواب
مجلس الشيوخ يبدو انه اكثر قربا للتصويت
عليه مجددا لنص المشروع الجديد لكن مجلس
النواب الامور ليست محسومه بعد هناك
معارضه شديده لنص هذا القانون وقد يلجا
الرئيس ماكرون والحكومه الى استخدام
الماده الدستوريه رقم
49,3 من اجل اقراره بالقوه من دون المرور
عبر مرحله التصويت اليوم هي الموجه
الثامنه كما ذكرتي من الاحتجاجات والاضراب
الاضرابات متواصله في عدد كبير من القط
خصوصا في قطاع النقل والطيران هناك 20% من
الرحلات الغيت اليوم من مطار اورلي ايضا
في مجال الطاقه في قطاع الطاقه هناك
اضرابات مستمره في مصافي النفط وايضا في
المحطات الاربعه التي تستورد الغاز
الموسال الى فرنسا كذلك هناك اضرابات في
قطاع التعليم والصحه وقطاعات اخرى كثيره
ايضا الابرز المشهد الابرز هو مشهد
القمامه في العاصمه باريس المنتشره منذ
تسعه ايام لا لم تزل
منتشره في كل الشوارع وهي تتكدس يوما بعد
يوم على كل جنبات الطرق يمكن رؤيتها نحن
هنا في الدائره الباريسيه الثامنه صناديق
القمامه كما ترون ما زالت منتشره والعمال
الذين
بداوا هذا الاضراب اعلنوا انه تمديده حتى
يوم الاثنين المقبل حتى مطلع الاسبوع
المقبل حتى الان حجم هذه القمامه المنتشره
في الشوارع تجاوز الاف طن في العاصمه
وحدها لكن ايضا هناك
اطنان منتشره في عدد كبير من المدن
الفرنسيه وهذا المشهد
بدا يقلق عدد كبير من الجهات خصوصا
الحكوميه لان التظاهره اليوم قد يتمكن
المتظاهرون من استخدام هذه القمامه وتكون
اداه في ايديهم لاشعالها في الشوارع لذلك
شرطه باريس قياده شرطه باريس وايضا وزير
الداخليه طالبا يوم امس من عمده مدينه
باريس ان تتحرك على الفور لتزيل هذه
القمامه على الاقل من مسار التظاهره كي لا
يتمكن المتظاهرون من الاستفاده منها للقاء
المقذوفات باتجاه عناصر الشرطه او حتى
اشعال النار فيها خلال مسيرهم في هذا
الموكب الباريسي
عربيه
نقلت وكاله بلومبرج عن مصادر مطلعه ان
التطبيق تيك توك سوف يدرس امكانيه
الانفصال عن شركه
الصينيه وذكرت الوكاله بان قرار الانفصال
تيك توك عن هذه الشركه الصينيه ياتي بهدف
تمديد المخاوف بشان مخاطر الامن القومي
الا ان هو بحسب المصادر يتعين على الحكومه
الصينيه الموافقه اولا على انفصال تيك توك
عن بعد
يعيش السوريون الناجون من الزلزال المدمر
في شمال غرب سوريا حاله اضطراب ما بعد
الصدمه حيث يرفض الكثيرين منهم العوده الى
منازلهم رغم انها لم تتضرر ويعزو المختصون
النفسيون ذلك لهول المشهد لحظه وقوع
الكارثه
ترقد تحت هذا الركام احلام قتلت ففي كل
منزل قصص وحكايا دفنت مع ابطالها صغارا
كانوا او كبارا اما الناجون فيلاحقهم
الخوف والرعب وبات العيش بين الجدران
كابوسا يؤرقهم مهند شاب سوري فقد اخويه
تحت الانقاض وعاش مع عائلته لولا اللحظات
الاولى لتارثه ورغم عدم تضرر منزله بات
يخشى العوده اليه لتغدو هذه الخيمه
مستقرهم الاشاعات اللي صارت الضعف
المعلومات اللي عنا الجيولوجي اللي احنا
ما بنعرف عنها شيء ابائنا واجدادنا ما
عاشوا هذه الفتره اللي صارت فنحن عنا خوف
مكبوت ما عم نفرجيه للاولاد للعيال فانا
كيف بدي اقنع عيلتي انه نروح نسكن وانا في
عندي خوف بداخلي من هذا اللي راح يصير
يعزو المختصون ارتفاع احصائيه الاصابه ما
بعد الصدمه خصوصا بين الاطفال في عموم
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال الى ما عاشه
السكان من خوف وذعر منذ لحظاته الاولى في
ناس تقريبا اصيبوا في هذا المرض وطبعا
النصيحه وهو هذا الاهم هو حسب تعامل الاهل
مع هذا الطفل او هذا الشخص اللي اصيب بهذا
المرض طبعا في عنا خطين خط الاول هو الاخذ
لطبيب نفسي والخط الثاني انه المعالجه
الشخصي بالبيت في ظل غيابي مراكز الصحه
النفسيه عن المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال
المدمر ومراكز الايواء والمخيمات يؤكد
ناشطون على ضروره العمل الجاد لاخراج
الناجين من هذا الاضطراب الذي اصاب
الكثيرين منهم ما بين مطرقه قصف النظام
والميليشيات الايرانيه على مدار سنوات
وسندان الخوف والمعاناه والنزوح اثر
الزلزال تستمر ماساه السوريين الذين باتت
الخيام اقصى احلامهم رغم ان قماشها لا يقي
برد الشتاء ولا حر الصيف محمد الاشقر
العربيه مدينه ادلب
اعلنت السفاره الامريكيه في الرياض مصادقه
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي على تعيين السفير
المعين مايكل راتني سفيرا لدى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وقالت السفاره في حسابها
على تويتر اننا نطلع الى ونتطلع الى
الترحيب بمايكل راتني في الرياض وفقا
لوزاره الخارجيه فان مايكل راتني هو عميد
كليه الدراسات دراسات اللغه في معهد
الخدمه الخارجيه بوزاره الخارجيه وهو موظف
قديم في السلك الديبلوماسي منذ العام 1990
في هذا المرشح الرئاسيه المحتمل للحزب
الديمقراطيه التقدمي ويليام بحمايه
الجزيره ضد الصين وضمان السلام لا ياكد
تسجيله رسميا لخوض الانتخابات التمهيديه
الرئاسيه مشيرا الى ان تايوان وقفت على
الخطوط الاماميه للديمقراطيه كما تتهمى
الصين بتوجيه تهديدات لفظيه وعسكريه
مباشره ضد تايوان تتواصل التدريبات
العسكريه المشتركه بين كوريا الجنوبيه
والولايات المتحده حيث اجرت قوات بريه
للبلدين مناوره على انشاء جسور لعبور
دبابات في محاكاه الاشتباك بري وقال
مسؤولون عسكريون ان واشنطن واسيول عززت
تعاون الدفاعي في مواجهه التهديدات
العسكريه والنوويه المتزايده من كوريا
الشماليه ضمن تدريبات درع الحريه
[موسيقى]
نهايه النشره تذكير بابرز العناوين
فاجنر تتقدم في بخمو توازيلين
باستخدام الفوسفور الابيض
بريطانيا تحذروا موسكو بعد تصادم طائره
مسيره امريكيه بمقاتله روسيه فوق البحر
الاسود
متظاهرون يحتشدون امام مطار بن غوريون
لمنع سفر نتنياهو الى برلين بسبب
التعديلات القضائيه
بحضور قادم فرنسي جلسه استجواب لحاكم مصرف
لبنان رياض سلامه في قضايا اختلاس اموال
عامه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]